Just as the night is dark and full of terrors,
the internet is vast and full of spoilers.
Game of Thrones has but two episodes remaining
in its epic eight-season run on television,
and thanks to a series of purported leaks,
fans may already have the answer as to how
the show will end.
Naturally, beware of some potentially massive
spoilers for the final episodes of the show.
Leaks for Game of Thrones season 8 began surfacing
online several months before the series returned
to HBO in April, and have continued to crop
up on various forums as the season has aired.
That leaked information has been compiled
by the Game of Thrones subreddit /r/freefolk,
with a recent update including potential details
about the last half of the final season.
Though many were initially hesitant to take
the leaks at face value, information provided
about episode 4 of the season wound up being
startlingly accurate.
With that in mind, people have become much
more inclined to believe the leaks about the
last two episodes are true.
According to the post on Reddit, the remaining
episodes of Game of Thrones season 8 will
allegedly feature the following developments,
not necessarily in this order.
Now's the time to look away.
Daenerys and her army will capture Jaime Lannister,
who was last seen heading back to King's Landing.
Dany also gives orders to execute Varys, presumably
for committing treason with his increasing
inclinations toward supporting Jon Snow and
protecting the citizens of the realm.
"I will act in their interest no matter the
personal cost."
He is reportedly burned alive.
All the while, Tyrion begs Daenerys to show
mercy, and attempts to resign as Hand, which
she refuses.
Jon Snow also attempts to reason with her,
and fails.
Instead of keeping a cool head in the face
of resistance, something snaps in Dany, and
she decides to storm King's Landing against
her advisors' wishes.
Her forces easily take the city in a one-sided
fight, and she also finally gets her chance
to light up Euron Greyjoy and the Iron Fleet.
From there, the leaked information alleges
that Daenerys and her Unsullied army will
dole out extreme violence in King's Landing,
further alienating Tyrion and Jon.
She begins executing many people.
Fed up with Daenerys' increasingly unhinged
actions, Tyrion frees Jaime and even attempts
to get Cersei to safety as well.
The leaks also claim that the chaos in King's
Landing will serve as the backdrop to the
long-awaited Clegane Bowl also known as the
battle between brothers the Hound and the
Mountain.
Both characters apparently die in the conflict.
The Mother of Dragons, apparently now in full
Mad Queen mode, arrests Tyrion for freeing
Jaime and sentences him to be executed.
Tyrion then allegedly does a complete 180
on his allegiance to Daenerys, and begins
attempting to convince Jon to turn on her.
In his view, Jon and the Stark family will
never be safe from an unhinged Daenerys, because
Jon's claim to the Throne serves as a threat
to her legitimacy.
Jon tries to talk to her, but is ignored,
with Daenerys believing her actions are justified.
With that avenue exhausted, Tyrion teams up
with Sansa to devise a plan to overthrow Dany
and turn Jon against her.
Despite agreeing to the plot at first, Sansa
ultimately betrays Tyrion.
"I used to think you were the cleverest man
alive."
Tyrion's trial is said to take place in the
Dragonpit, and is said to have Samwell Tarly,
Brienne of Tarth, Grey Worm, and Robin Arryn
of all people in attendance, among others.
Tyrion gives an enraged and resentful monologue,
criticizing the onlookers for turning against
him despite his many sacrifices for the people
of King's Landing.
But he can't talk his way out of this one.
He slumps to his knees, defeated.
Though the details aren't clear yet, he reportedly
dies.
That's not all.
Additionally, Jaime will fight Euron, killing
the crazed Greyjoy man but sustaining fatal
injuries himself.
Jaime is said to make his way back to Cersei,
and the two die together, though who kills
who and why is still unknown.
Finally, the leaks make a bold claim about
how Jon and Dany's story ends.
After failing to get through to Daenerys and
make her see that her sack of King's Landing
was wrong, Jon ultimately kills her.
According to the purported leaks, Kit Harington
shot two possible endings for his character,
so Jon will either take the black and join
a new Night's Watch, or will die before the
end of the final episode.
This information reportedly comes from several
different sources that mostly corroborate
each other, though some leaks have information
that other sources don't.
According to one leak, the series will end
with a council deciding that Bran should rule
the Seven Kingdoms.
Sansa will rule the North, and Samwell, Bronn,
and Ser Davos will serve as Bran's advisers.
Interestingly, this leak also insists that
Tyrion will be among Bran's advisers, Tyrion
will be among Bran's advisers, contradicting
the other leaks that say he dies.
It also seems to contradict Bran's previous
statements about desiring any kind of power
at all.
And that's it that's the information that's
out there.
Parts of it may well be true, and other parts
may be deliberate misinformation seeded by
the production to muddy the spoiler waters.
Either way, it sounds like an ending that's
determined to frustrate, ending the series
on what sounds like an incredibly divisive
note.
Only time will tell, but if the bulk of these
turn out to be accurate, let's just say that
King's Landing isn't the only thing that will
go up in flames the internet probably will,
too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.